dare you how dare you create a world in
which there is such misery that is not
our fault it's not right it's utterly
utterly evil do you know his name i
think stephen fish i believe because the
god who created this universe if it was
created by god is quite clearly a maniac
utter maniac
god is so great if god is so kind
they've got a son of benevolent i've got
us so nice why is there evil in the
world why are little children you know
dying from cancer like he said what
people are really after is what is my
stance on religion or spirituality or
god
[Music]
now my next special guest is no stranger
to the show
we have a lot to talk about my brother a
lot to catch up on i miss this guy mrs
brother this is going to be a very
exciting informative educational
purposeful enlightening show insha'allah
god willing could end up being a
life-changing episode for those who are
open-minded and searching for the truth
and meaning in life going from
meaningless to meaningful
without further ado
my brother your brother
faraz
how are you
good how's it going amazing thank you
good to see you again it's been two it's
been it lis it's been too long i know i
know they got i know they got you locked
up there in canada you guys can't move
but
yeah it's pretty it's pretty rough here
it's getting better it's getting a lot
better now there's a new uh
omni-kuran scare so uh you know we're
trying to keep it um we're hoping it
doesn't escalate like it did the last
year
but uh yeah no the canadian government
is uh very uh
i should i say uh very adamant vodkovic
how about you guys how's everything in
chicago i mean same thing pretty much
not as bad as uh in in
canada
but uh you know that's a whole different
discussion you know it's uh it's crazy
but uh alhamdulillah i wanted to uh we
have a lot to catch up on i'm kind of
going to be all over the place
but but uh i want to get your i want to
start off with this um
this video and i want to get your
reaction to it
and from there we'll take off suppose
it's all true
and you walk up to the pearly gates and
you are confronted by god
what will stephen fry say to him her or
it
i will basically
that is the odyssey i think i i'll say
bone cancer in children what's that
about
how dare you how dare you create a world
in which there is such misery that is
not our fault it's not right it's
utterly utterly evil why should i
respect a capricious mean-minded stupid
god who creates a world which is so full
of injustice and pain
that's what i would say
and you think you're going to get in
but i wouldn't want to i wouldn't want
to get in on his terms they're wrong now
if i died and it was
it was pluto hades and if it was the 12
greek gods then i would have more truck
with it because the greeks were
they didn't pretend not to be human in
their appetites and in their
capriciousness and in their
unreasonableness they didn't present
themselves as being all seen all wise
all kind all beneficent because the god
who created this universe if it was
created by god is quite clearly
a maniac
utter maniac
totally selfish total we have to spend
our life on our knees thanking him
what kind of god would do that yes the
world is very splendid but it also has
in it insects whose whole life cycle is
to burrow into the eyes of children and
make them blind they eat outwards from
the eyes
why why did you do that to us
you could easily have made a creation in
which that didn't exist it is simply not
acceptable
so you know atheism isn't not just about
them not believing there is a is not
believing there's a god but
on the assumption there is one what kind
of god is he it's perfectly apparent
that he's
monstrous utterly monstrous and deserves
no respect whatsoever
the moment you banish him your life
becomes simpler purer cleaner
more worth living in my
opinion
a lot to unpackage here but i think i
think i got the right man for the job
where do you want where do you want to
start what did you do you didn't minute
to to uh dissect everything no no no no
no this is universal
yeah a very classic question you know
and i have a lot to say about are you
familiar with this famous actor of
course not the actor no no but the the
argument yes yeah but he's a pretty
famous uh actor comedian in the uk yeah
what's it do you know his name i think
stephen fish i believe
okay no i'm not familiar i'm sure you
know he looks familiar i'm sure i've
seen him on tv but uh no i'm not sure i
i wouldn't i wouldn't know he was an
actor if you ask me what is he i would
have thought he's on tv but i don't know
if he's so people are listening to this
man i mean this guy makes a statement
and you got millions of people who are
listening to him and many get influenced
right
well
you know he he's in he's taking a
self-defeating position this is known
what he's what he's talking about is
known as the problem of
evil epicurus said you know he said look
if if god is so great if god is so kind
that god is so benevolent if god is so
nice why is there evil in the world why
are little children you know dying from
cancer like he said why is there evil in
the world
either god doesn't care he's not so nice
or he can't do anything about it either
way he's not a god so if a god if he was
a god if he was perfect he would care
and prevent it
and if he cannot prevent it then he's
not all powerful therefore he's not a
god so in their mind they're saying look
there's they can't be a god
but here's the here's where they shoot
themselves in the foot here's where the
position is self-defeating and again
this is a very old argument what he's
bringing up it's a very very old
argument it's a very short-sighted
argument
is
how would you know there's evil
if there is no god
if we live in a cold dead universe
if we are nothing but chemicals
and and and
particles if we're nothing if we're
nothing but materialism if everything is
chemistry and physics
it would be like saying sticks and
stones are complaining about evil if we
are just sticks and stones if we are
just physics and chemistry
there is no such thing if there is no
god there is no such thing as evil
by saying you see an evil in the world
you are admitting
you are admitting
that there is a god you know this is not
not just me saying this is a rationalist
throughout the ages
because there is without god there is no
evil
without god there is no right and wrong
if there's no god everything is
permissible this is a classic quote here
throughout
forgetting the author's name but if ever
if there is no god everything is
permissible there is no halal or had on
there is no good or bad there's no evil
how come if we are nothing but machinery
how come this is the classic rebuttal to
this question how come if we are
machinery how come if we're
how come if we are nothing but
physics and chemistry
how do you even know how come you're
conscious of evil this is the question
now he has to have some introspect here
and he's going to say look i see the
world as good and bad
but there is this is a classic
question in the works of plato
it's called the the youthful dilemma
does god say something is haram because
it does god say something is evil or
good
because
it has the germ of evil or good within
it
or
is it evil or good because god said so
it could have been murder could have
been good if god said murder is good he
could have flipped it it's relative to
what god's opinion is
or is murder in itself evil this is a
euthyphro euthyphro
dilemma this man is saying look i see
evil in the world but i don't see a god
there is no evil in the world if the
world is
if you are truly an atheistic
materialist philosopher
it's a self-defeating position there is
no evil why do you think
stalin and hitler could kill millions of
people and then sleep well at night
because in their minds
they didn't believe there was good or
evil
killing somebody if i remove your head
off your shoulders it's the same as if i
move this coffee mug from one place to
the other on my desk it's just i took
material and i rearranged material from
one place to another if you're truly an
atheist a human being is just a machine
it's like it's like removing the wheel
off your car and replacing it with
another wheel or or scrapping your car
completely it's just
physics and chemistry there is nothing
else
by saying
by saying he sees evil in the world
this is what uh hume called you can't
get
an ought from an is the world is this
way and now you're saying it ought to be
this this other way so for instance he
sees a child with cancer and he's saying
look it ought to be a child with no
cancer that child should have a perfect
life
human saying look if we're going to be
atheists
if we're going to say there's no god we
cannot say ut
we cannot say this the world should
ought to be like this
if we are atheist so the fact that he's
taking this position is self-defeating
now i have a lot more things to say but
i i want to let you jump in on this but
it's interesting he also how is he
connecting he's talking about now the
pagan gods also he starts diverting and
talking about these pagan gods
yeah i think he's trying to say that
look the pagan gods weren't perfect you
know they were more human than the
god of the monotheistic religion you
know the god of because the pagan gods
were selfish they went to war with each
other they're very human-like
so he's saying it's mo it's more
logical to believe in them
right yeah
i think it's making more of a joke
because they're obviously not true but
at least they're cooler you know they're
they're more uh
i could understand that those gods would
build this world world because they were
selfish and they don't they don't really
care too much about human beings
sometimes they like certain human beings
and they favor them and other times they
dislike certain certain human beings and
those are the gods that we may just make
human beings make up in their own mind
yeah of course yeah it's a it's a what
we call a compounded idea yeah you take
the idea of god you take the idea of war
and then you make the water
you know so it's a compounded idea and
it's not it's not a an idea that's
experienced in the world so
he i think he was kind of making a joke
he's kind of say look don't tell me you
have a perfect god because look at his
works
look at his works
because you have to understand like
many thinkers like
to leibniz whether they were muslim or
christian thinkers they said look the
world we live in is a perfect world
the world we live in is a perfect world
why because god made the world hence
it's perfect it's your interpretation of
the world it's human interpretation of
the world
that it's the lack of faith that gives
us this imperfect
view now this is a very uh uh concrete
islamic idea in my opinion when you read
the quran the quran is telling you the
world was made this way on purpose
when when you see a child uh who has
cancer like he mentioned there is a head
like we say in in islam we say there's a
good in there that you don't see you'll
see once you have the totality of
evidence
you don't have the totality of evidence
yet but there is a wisdom behind it
there's something very good see he he's
working from a faulty premise what's his
name again the gentleman
uh i believe it's f stephen fish let me
double check yeah
though this this gentleman here whatever
his name is
yeah i wish i could address somebody's
name but uh
he's he's he's presupposing
he's
stephen yeah stephen fry stephen fry
okay stephen fry yeah not fish stephen
fry supposing
that death is the greatest evil because
he's an atheist he thinks that when you
die the lights go out and that's it you
can't have any more worldly pleasures
therefore you've been cut off from
experience you've been excluded from
experience
he's presupposing it's the end but what
if death is not the end let's say death
is just another
dimension you enter another dimension
maybe that child that died from cancer
is in a place right now of comfort he
doesn't know that he's presupposing the
child's
fate was a disastrous one
he hasn't crossed over from life to
death
he's presupposing that and this is clear
in the quran you know you're
presupposing you it says you know it
talks about martyrs don't say they're
dead
they're alive you just perceive it not
you don't perceive it so
the quran is telling you look don't
presuppose you know everything don't
think you have the totality of evidence
there is more to come
and that more to come
if you have faith death to you is not so
final
so this is a counter-argument he is
presupposing something he has no proof
of
now it's like for instance if you
imagine you look at a child okay and
your child
breaks his toy let's say he breaks the
story and your child's in torment
because his toy is broken
you look at your child and you're
thinking look this is just such a small
event in your life you're gonna get over
it
there's so many good things coming your
way that the parent when you look at the
child you kind of smile that he's crying
over his broken toe you know you're
going to replace it for him like this
you know you're going to make things
better for him and this is just a little
bump in the road and also it's going to
help him mature in a way there's some
good in this etc how you look at your
child
the wiser man will look at you and of
course god will look at us
when somebody dies
if your narrative is that's the end of
course i understand he's tormented i
understand that he feels that way i
understand that he
he he's having negative thoughts
but in the in the believer's mind
in the religious mind we don't see it as
the end
so
he's taking a different narrative and
he's presupposing that narrative to be
true
you know in the quran it tells you
when you're resurrected when you live
again god's gonna ask you how long were
you in this world the present world
we're in today and we're going to see it
as a very temporary amount of time oh a
day maybe a day and a half
similar to how you remember a dream
when you're dreaming if you're having a
nightmare
to you that nightmare
you know maybe the dream was 20 minutes
but in your mind that dream was
an eternity or it was
uh you know for you it was a lifetime
let's call it
when you wake up from the dream you're
like oh it's just a dream you don't
lament about it you don't wish that it
never happened
you move on it was a little bump in the
road and there was something you can
take from it and you had an experience
you've experienced
a bad dream so you appreciate your good
dreams there's some wisdom there that we
can discuss we can unpack later however
you don't lament about it and say why
did i have this bad dream i'm never i
never want to dream again i'm never
going to fall asleep again i never want
to experience i never i don't want to go
on anymore because i had a bad dream in
islam we like in this world the quran
likens this world
as a dream
and uh
all everything's gonna be made right
everything's gonna be made right this is
what emmanuel kant you know uh that's
why i was fascinated by emmanuel kant
because he was his philosophies even
though he wasn't muslim he was so close
like by using a reason he came he said
he came so close to what things what's
what what are said things that are said
in islam actually
and i was even more surprised when i saw
his phd thesis and he wrote on on his
phd thesis he wrote bismillah
which was shocking to me and uh you know
who was this again this was
uh
emmanuel kant was is arguably one of the
greatest thinkers of all time and he
wrote on his thesis in the name of allah
the most gracious the most merciful
that's correct you know he's talking
about something
which is fascinating to me and nobody
really even knows why like we have
there's a lot of theories on why and one
of them is that he was very influenced
by a
a contemporary of his a friend of his
name gote gotta is like they call him
the german shakespeare
one of the greatest intellects in
history
and gothi had incredible uh reverence
for the quran he absolutely loved the
quran he actually got actually said it's
our duty to believe in the quran he
actually wrote a poem about the prophet
like he was so adamant about
christianity excuse me islam
that
some peop some people believe that maybe
that's where khan
got this influence and there's a lot of
theories on how that that
those letters got on his
on his thesis but
if you if you listen to if you
listen to one of khan's arguments it's
very islamic it's incredibly islamic
he says look
i believe in the soma bonum the son of
bonam is the greatest good
and now this is very interesting okay
it's extremely interesting argument
because
i believe that
it's it's extremely i mean it's embedded
in the quran like you can't you can't
deny it it comes from the quran
he says look i look into the world and i
see a lot of evil i see things i see bad
people get away with things
and they live in old age and they die
and they die comfortably in their bed
it's not fair okay i'm paraphrasing i
mean it doesn't work like this at all
i'm just kind of giving you a modern
rendition of it okay
some guy was really evil lived a good a
good life meaning he his belly was full
he had a nice house he had riches he had
all the things of the of the you know
that anybody would want uh he can you
know yeah plenty of resources and he
died comfortably at his bed
but he was a bad guy you know he's he
abused the people he was a he was a drug
lord whatever it may be whatever evils
he he made his money with
and then he goes in the grave and cat is
saying
it can't be how it ends
not to say there must be an afterlife
and things are made
just
why did he say that like how did he make
that logical leap he says look
i have within me this moral law because
i can i can see evil and good
i see good and bad there could be no
such uh
conscious experience without god
god put in with us a moral law
so he likens it to seeing something
beautiful like he sees you know you see
the starry skies above the star skies
above are beautiful why would you see
beauty if we're just if we are just
machinery if we are just
physics and chemistry if we are just
sticks and stones so to speak
if we are just valves opening and
closing
there would be no beauty there would be
no morality there would be no sense of
good and evil we are touched by
something
and this is where i i'll i'll give you a
famous agnostic because this is not just
people who are religious that say this
like for instance a famous agnostic said
something
uh amazing i find he said something
incredible
that i think is lost on most people he
said and this is a thomas huxley i'm
quoting now and they call him darwin's
bulldog because he was very adamant
about darwinism he was darwin's greatest
defender
in his time
so they called him darwin's bulldog he
said look
says
he says the mind the brain
and the mind is like if i took a a lamp
you know a lamp and i rubbed it and a
magic genie came out
imagine taking a lamp just it's just
chemistry and physics and i rub it and a
magic genie came out he says look if the
brain
if why is the brain a physical thing
something that when it gets excited a
mind comes
of it
you have consciousness you have all
these inner experiences you have this
realm this dimension
where
good and evil exists where morality
exists
he said look this is divine this is
something
outside of chemistry chemistry and
physics now in the quran the way it's
explained god creates adam from a clay
or mud or whatever you want to say and
then he breathes into him something very
unique his rule something something
divine we're touched by something divine
now that's
how the quran puts it but you have a you
have a first person experience of this
yes your body is an object in the world
we have we live in the world we
we are sticks and stones to a certain
degree i am part chemistry and physics
yet however within us there's something
else there's this thing that's alien
it's transcendent
and even cut admits to this
khan says look how do i have this
morality in me this morality in me is
telling me that there's more
there is good and bad and the balances
have to be at the end of the day
has to be
the debt has to be paid
if it wasn't the case if it was untrue
that there's a next life and morality
and
why would i have this this inner
this inner calling this inner
uh experience sticks and stones could
never have this leap
this is oftentimes called that referred
to in our modern days absurdism think
about it
imagine
it's just another way of think about it
absurd absurdism is another way of
thinking about it imagine
every human being
we're born with this sense to connect
with something greater
what is the meaning of all this
if the world if the world we live in had
no meaning it would be the greatest
absurdity
it would be the absolute greatest
absurdity the argument to say that
the universe
if we're just universe if we're just
chemicals and
chemistry physics then we're just
talking to ourselves it's we are the
universe talking to itself
meaninglessly
that is the most absurd idea
possible
because it would be like a robot
becoming conscious and realizing that
his existence is futile
it's referred to as absurdism
yeah
i wanna go ahead and connect another
term that's often used so you have
atheism he's an atheist
and also
this statement that you believe
which
uh we can go ahead substantiate you know
that it's a
we'll get into that is this actually a
true statement or somebody covering up
what's just intrinsically
part of their fitness part of their
nature so there's another term here by
an old friend of ours
that last time you were in chicago we we
we talked about
some of the things he's discusses let's
get into this and then we can connect
the two terms often asked
and occasionally in an accusatory way
are you atheist
you know the only ist i am
is a scientist
all right i don't associate with
movements i don't i'm not in
ism
i just
i think for myself the moment once
someone attaches you to
a philosophy or a movement then they
assign all the baggage and all the rest
of the philosophy that goes with it to
you
and when you want to have a conversation
they will assert that they already know
everything important there is to know
about you because of that association
and that's not the way to have a
conversation
i'm sorry it's not
i'd rather we explore each other's ideas
in real time
rather than assign a label to it and
assert you know what's going to happen
in advance
so
what people are really after is what is
my stance on religion or spirituality or
god and i would say and i would say if
i'd find a word that came closest it
would be agnostic there you go that's
the term so we got atheism
atheist agnostic connecting these two
and you're familiar with uh obviously
the scientists
uh we discussed last time neil yeah neil
degrasse tyson
is a very famous uh
figure so people will think how can
someone
who is deeply into science
when you compare the bedouin who's
walking in the desert and he sees the
footsteps he doesn't have the kind of
degrees the scientist has but he sees
the footsteps of the camel and he knows
you know no he sees the dung and the
footsteps of the camel he knows the
camel was here right and then if when he
looks at the universe he knows that okay
this equals that there has to be a
creator of the universe and then a great
thinker ibn tamiya he says you're asking
me for signs you know of of the crater
and you're blind to all the signs around
you they're all over so how does this
guy who sees looks out into the universe
he sees all of this and he doesn't see
well you know what i i respect his view
he's saying look i don't want to tell
you what isms i'm closest to because
then you're just going to label me i
understand he wants us to
unpack his ideas one by one he wants it
you know he's saying look
you know two scientists
we're in ist but we don't necessarily
believe the exact same things two
christians don't necessarily believe the
same thing per se two muslims don't
necessarily exactly believe the same
thing so i understand that point of view
it makes sense
um he's saying i'm agnostic i understand
why he's agnostic because in
science you have to understand science
is a is what we call an epistemology
it's inducted it's based on inductive
logic
if i didn't see it if i didn't
ultimately ultimately
it starts with the senses we have to see
it hear it touch it taste it smell it
fundamentally speaking
science is based on inductive reasoning
then after that we impose the deduction
okay so
they say look don't assume anything you
have to have a hypothesis then an
experiment and then you make
observations there is a method to the
way they put they produce
facts
theories facts laws
there's a they have a system
now the system is not
uh
there's not one definition to the system
things can be more scientific than other
things you know there are degrees of how
scientific something can be how much
control they can have
they have a system and in a system
you try not to presuppose anything
if you it's trying to be as objective as
possible
objective meaning look i'm not trying to
put my personal beliefs into this
conclusion i have this idea i'm trying
to prove it to the world and i'm trying
to say look i'm taking my own personal
biases out
the more you can remove personal bias
and subjectivity from a
scientific experiment the more it's
considered to be scientific
so he's he's as a scientist he has to
remove his own personal ideas and
beliefs
from his conclusions
so i understand and his point of view
however
philosophers when we ask what does
science actually show us what is science
because for instance if we ask you know
what is architecture well architecture
is a science it's the it's the art let's
call it the art of
building structures
okay great what's martial arts martial
arts is the art of defending yourself
okay what is science science ultimately
boils down
when philosophers of science when we ask
them what is this animal you call
science what does it do for us
well it predicts
patterns irregularities
found in nature whatever we believe that
patterns irregularities of the past will
occur again in the future so they're not
talking their their job is not to talk
about spirituality or god they're not
looking for god science is not looking
for god that's why science doesn't tell
us anything about god unless we go into
the philosophy of science okay now
that's a subject what does science do
science is trying to tell us
here are the patterns and regularities
we find in nature it's it's moot to sign
it doesn't talk about god at all it has
nothing to you could be an atheist
scientist or you could be a serious
believer in god and be scientific people
conflate this all the time science is
trying to tell us
what medicines cure what ills
and
that's just a science of medicine in
every in every domain of science science
is trying to tell us
these are the patterns and regularities
we have in this domain that's it it
doesn't talk about god it doesn't talk
about introspection it doesn't talk
about morality in science there is no
morality there is no uh you know uh
there is no psychology
they're trying to remove psychology out
of again psychology is a different
science but they're trying to remove any
bias they can
so he's taking that approach saying look
i'm not trying to
be biased therefore i'm trying to be
agnostic i understand his point of view
but he must have a personal opinion
now if his opinion is look i haven't
figured out whether i believe in god or
not that's fine
but science won't tell us
necessarily
because the thing is look
do you believe that god is in the in the
dunya no we don't believe god is a
bearded man above the sky
this is a very important point because
many people very important
because that many people go away from
belief in the creator of the heavens and
earth because they think he's some old
man with a beard in the heavens
there's a meme online that says it's a
it's an astronaut up in the up in the
in the space and he's putting a sign up
saying i see no god up here
well nobody believes that there's a god
up there
up there above the clouds with a beard
and a staff you know like
that's why islam when you when you study
islam is especially islam in in judaism
we tell you god is not in the dunya you
can look under every rock you can look
go in the deepest ocean you can go up in
the highest half you're not gonna god is
not in a time and space living in a
little hut
somewhere nothing encompasses god god is
not part of the dunya it is a part of
the fl the flesh of this world
so
there you don't expect scientists to
find god in their high drunken life do
you think
do you think they are influenced because
we're creatures of imitation and now
many of the peers and then i don't know
if you've seen this documentary uh
expelled no intelligence allowed have
you seen that ever it's a really good
documentary
um
i might have seen highlights i'm not
familiar with it too much but i've heard
that term before and i think it's a
christian guy right i believe i believe
so
oh yes i've seen i've seen a few extract
i i remember now yeah they have a really
really good documentary
yes it's called sweatshirts about design
yeah it's a really good documentary and
at the end you see that people who argue
for a creator they're pretty much
ostracized right they're not given a
platform they're blacklisted so do you
think uh neil tyson now
if he starts to come out and he argues
he's influenced by his surroundings by
his peers which institution that's
pushing out you know god from the
equation even if now they found proof
they would suppress the proof most
likely that's how the system is set up
well
here's the thing
i'm i'm a nominalist okay muslims are
nominalists but they don't know it
grazelli was a nominalist there's no
doubt you know if you ask any expert on
zelda they're gonna say of course he was
a nominalist they erect one god or the
other
so we say god they say nature
let me explain okay
if i ask you i'll give you a little
taste of nominalism okay we hear that a
lot yes nature i i tell them nature
doesn't exist it's a mother it's a god
in your imagination they'll say mother
nature
it's a god in their imagination bring me
a plea i challenge i'm making an
official challenge okay
any scientist in the world
bring me on to any podcast have a civil
discussion and you prove to me that
nature is an existing force in the
universe i i'll i'll be shocked
please i i there's no way to prove it i
i've i've searched the world
for a proof
uh i've searched three thousand years of
philosophy for a proof there is no proof
and anybody want to take me up on this
challenge please bring me on and let's
have a public civil discussion and you
prove to me that nature is actually a
force out there okay so if i ask you if
i ask you eddie what is nature uh a
hundred scientists have asked a hundred
times in nature like well he's gonna
have to give me examples he's gonna have
to go to what we call particulars he's
gonna say look
and this by the way is is is in the
quran okay so
i
if people who've read the quran are
gonna be familiar with what i'm saying
you're gonna have to tell me look at
that plant over there you see that
flower
well that flower is going through a
process we call natural and this force
behind it this natural force
you plant a seed you bury it you water
it you give it this much
uh uh
uh you give it these these circumstances
it's just start to flower in blue
over time it's gonna reach this stage
where it blooms
and i'm asked okay so if i destroy every
flower in the world there's no more
nature they're gonna say no
nature's also that stream over there you
see that stream
nature is also the clouds in the air
nature is also the sunshine nature is
also the stars in the sky nature is also
the planetary bodies nature is also
they're going to keep giving me all
these particulars
now when they say nature when they say
the word nature
they're making
a collective claim a universal claim to
all these objects see
it's funny because neil degrasse tyson
was saying look i don't want to give you
what ism or ist i am because you're
going to make this collective claim
about me
you're going to think you know
everything of what how i think you're
going to you're going to think you know
everything about me i want you to come
and dialogue with me and let me give you
what i think bit by bit so you could
truly understand me it's kind of it's
it's there's a parallel here when you
say nature you're talking about all
these things out there you're talking
about the desert sands you're talking
about the
the the
the rain the the water cycle you're
talking about all these things you're
just when you say nature you're calling
you're calling upon all these objects
you're not truly calling upon a force
why think about this okay this is what i
want to challenge all
everybody out there with
first you saw the cycles
of flowers blooming bling planted
a new flower blooms that drops its seed
on the ground and then the seed is
buried again and then it blooms again
you first you saw that cycle and then
you called it then you added the label
nature
you didn't start with the idea of nature
and then go out in the world and
discover flowers and water cycles and
wind and and planetary bodies no no it
was it's the opposite
the universal is dependent on the
particular
the universal nature is the universal
this force that you're appealing to
first you saw
all the particulars
the water cycle
the wind
sunshine photo everything that
we call nature first you saw the
particulars and then you added the label
nature yes
and islam is telling you don't
add the label what came before the
particulars
what came before these particulars what
caused these particulars it's not what
you labeled the particulars with later
because the word nature is a meaningless
term it has it's just a noise we make
with our mouth to label to call upon all
these particulars not an easy point for
people to understand okay it's i
understand how how difficult it is to
understand because when i first studied
philosophy i came upon these ideas and
they were difficult it took me years to
contemplate and think about it and try
to understand you know i'm not trying to
uh tell you guys that this is easy stuff
to understand but there are no
universals out there
there are know universals
in in the the way scientists present
this when they say nature
they're erecting another force out there
another god another deity another
something
that we don't
do me a favor ask any scientist to put
nature in a test tube
they can't it's a concept
nature is a concept
we're asking you for particulars don't
bring on your concepts we don't want to
hear about your concepts you want to
hear about our concept we don't want to
hear about your god just tell us what
the what the experiments about tell us
what tell us what's objective
the word nature is a subjective term it
is not an objective term it is never
observed in the is never observed out
there in the world
it's a concept it's an ideology it's a
philosophy we add on to
what we've experienced and it came after
the fact
that's what's so important because don't
forget the quran asks you to look into
the world
and notice these cycles
but when you say nature you're adding
the label afterwards when we say god
we're saying god was before the cycle
this force before the cycle
because if i took out every particular
in nature let's say i removed all the
planetary bodies all the stars all the
the water cycle if i removed everything
you wouldn't know anything about nature
your your your idea of god your idea of
of this force this god this god you call
nature depends on these particulars
we're saying no god came before the
particulars that's why we call him god
not nature we say god is something else
god is before the particulars the
particulars depend on god not the other
way around
nature depends on our observation of
particulars if we didn't observe those
particulars if we lived in a totally
empty universe we wouldn't say we
wouldn't have came up with the idea of
this universal idea called nature
you understand
hence
god is saying look
i'm before the particulars the
particulars depend on me
i brought them into existence
nature could not bring anything to
existence because nature is a byproduct
this is very important nature is a
byproduct of the particulars
the particular things we observe in in
the world
nature is a byproduct we the quran is is
brilliant and saying look god is no
byproduct
of the imagination
god is before the particulars the
particulars depend on nobody nobody says
in in science oh all these particulars
depend on nature no nature came after
your idea of nature is a byproduct of
the particulars
let's go ahead and connect now we have
the term atheist
and then we have the agnostic and now we
got another
brother a good friend of yours i don't
know well i don't know if he's good
friend of mine you know him definitely
and let's see uh if h
is he being influenced somehow
because uh it seems like uh
well let's just get into the clip see
what you think
you and your beard my friend
i have beard envy what is it well i
inverted i'm now a muslim what is the
significance behind this this beard i
love it no real reason you know i wanted
to grow it out kind of do like a troll
thank you so much how are you joe rogan
i'm good sir how are you doing oh man
i'm doing that that is so good
after
all the pressure
all the chaos
everything that has happened in your
life up to this moment how good does it
feel to be back to be victorious and to
have that ufc gold around your waist
right now hey you know what
without god i am absolutely nothing all
glory be to god well i converted i'm now
muslim
all right so alhamdulillah
so we got everything encapsulated one
step alhamdulillah he's praising the
creator of the heavens and the earth
it's a term that habib often uses after
his fights he's not pointing to himself
he's pointing up above to the creator
heavens and the earth and he's saying
that he's accepted islam submission to
the creator not the creation and i'm
probably maybe he's just being facetious
what are your thoughts on that when you
see that but then but just one thing you
have so you have now someone from you
know
atheism agnostic to someone like john
jose who's a believer obviously in the
creator of the heavens and earth yeah
john is definitely a believer i i know
he comes from a christian family i know
his father's a pastor i'm not sure if
it's pastor or reverend i'm not sure
what level he's at or which one which
dominate the nomination he is
you know i trained with john many years
ago so we've lost touch over time i saw
him recently uh um was it this summer i
saw him this summer
or this spring i saw him and uh you know
i only see the positive side like when i
meet john i i've only seen he's always
he's always been good to me and i've
never seen him do anything bad now i
know he's done many bad things but he's
not uh you know he's he's had many
troubles in the media let's say
um but when he's
when i interact with him and with the
years we're training together he's never
shown me that side you know so um he's
saying alhamdulillah
is he studying islam i have no idea i've
lost touch with him i haven't talked to
him i haven't had a deep discussion with
him in many many years
um now when i see him we just shake
hands hug say hello i don't know what's
going on in his personal life uh but
he's been in the media for for he's had
some trouble in the media in the past
and very recently so i really don't know
what's going on with him uh
to that level
but it seems like so you have people now
uh that are suppressing the fit up you
talk about you know you made a statement
which i i would say i agree with you
know this is uh something that there
there is truly there is no such thing as
atheism or
uh no such thing as a atheist
can you click can you look can you can
you elucidate on that
yeah because you know they tell me look
they don't believe in my god i believe i
say i don't believe in atheism i don't
believe in nature literally
because i believe when when they appeal
to nature you know they say oh we're you
know darwin proved that it's all nature
it's
nature what do you mean uh evolution is
just nature nature if you cross-examine
it is just a an idea it's a concept
that is
it's
superimposed on particulars it's a
universal as we say in philosophy so for
instance they say they say that
a classic example neil degrasse tyson i
remember watching his documentary i want
to use his example so that it's nice and
neat and
and i paraphrase this point he says look
polar bears were let's say excuse me
bears were brown or black and then one
day one bear had a genetic error genetic
mutation
they classified as an error
but through a blind process
he became white and he gave him an
advantage for hunting in snow therefore
he excelled in hunting and snow he
passed on his genetics now polar bears
exist polar bears had a genetic mutation
and error they say
an error and that error led to white
polar bears okay i'm paraphrasing i'm
putting in a nutshell it's there's many
more details to it but they're saying
look there was an error the thing is an
error the word error is a human
narrative
it's a human narrative a blind process
cannot make an error
the the difference is not what we're
seeing what we we all admit to the same
facts
it could very well be
that
polar bears used to be brown and there
was a genetic mutation
and certain polar certain bears became
white and had an advantage i had an
advantage in hunting in this in arctic
areas snowy areas and therefore they
they propagated their genes and now you
have polar bears it could very well be
however your story that it's an error
that i don't have to accept that's
that's subjective that's your narrative
it's not found in the data it's not
found in the observation
i'm saying that god mutated that that
that dna that was on purpose that was
god's plan god is the selector god god
chose some bears to survive and some
bears to die
some bears had mutations that were not
success were not helpful for them in
their environment and some
had
advantages you know the quran calls god
the selector
it's it doesn't go against the quran it
doesn't go against what we believe it's
the narrative you're superimposing a
narrative and they don't realize it
where is this narrative observed in
nature it's never observed in nature
it's observed in your own mind anybody
who studies can't knows that the reason
why you call it
an error is because of your own paradigm
now paradigm if you could think about it
is imagine you're wearing roasted rose
tinted glasses you would see the world
as
tinted rose if you had blue tinted
glasses you would see the world as blue
your paradigm is how you filter out
information the narrative you
superimpose so that's why we ask
what are the hard facts keep your
narratives to yourself
now
i can add a different narrative that
i can add a different narrative to the
same body of facts it doesn't make me
illogical
i'm not denying the facts
so muslims should never deny the facts
but we don't have to accept their
narratives narratives change over time
and some narratives are weeded out and
some narratives
are uh strengthened over time to say
to say that it's a genetic error
is actually
logically it's consistent with the term
blind process because blind process has
no intention it's to say that nature had
an intention again they're erecting this
god they think that nature has this
direction if nature is truly a blind
process there are no errors
again they're always
they're always admitting
secretly
that there's an intention in the
universe by saying there's an error it's
amazing because in darwinism they say
there is this random mutation again
randomness i've talked about in the past
it's just another god they erect it's
just more narrative it's not found
randomness is never found in nature ever
ever and it's hilarious
because science and mathematics tell us
that the world is determined
in determinism there are there is no
random events
they can't have it both ways actually
contradict themselves at a philosophical
level
that's why einstein famously said
god doesn't play dice with the universe
the universe is
perfectly determined
the universe
is perfectly determined there are no
random events so to say for a biologist
says look there's this random event he's
using that as an expression because if
he means it literally he's saying
something that goes against
newtonian physics like he's violating
newtonian physics here we can't have
biology we can't put biology over
newtonian physics newtonian physics is
more certain now there are levels of
logic there are levels of fats okay
all facts are not created equal a
mathematical fact cannot be likened to a
an inductive fact
mathematics is more certain than
inductive facts there are there's a
hierarchy of facts a historical fact is
not to is not as certain as a
mathematical fact
a historical fact is not as certain
as a
inductive fact a scientific fact there
are levels of facts okay if you study
epistemology that's what epistemology is
you know how do we know something how
did you how did you get to this
conclusion what type of logic did you
use there are different types of logic
most people out there in the world
cannot tell you the difference between
deductive logic and inductive logic
something that's very basic in in
epistemology that's epistemology 101 if
you could not to tell if you cannot tell
the difference between inductive
reasoning and detective reasoning uh you
shouldn't have an opinion on what i just
said you should not if you're not a
professional you shouldn't have an
opinion on this inductive facts and
deductive facts and historical facts and
intuitive facts are different things
scientists are giving us sometimes their
personal outlook in life and they don't
realize it that's why i want to weed it
out just give me the science i i want to
make your your conclusions even more
pure so for instance that gentleman at
the beginning his name was steve uh
what was it again
fry steve fry he's saying look i see
evil in the world
[Laughter]
that's his own subjective view
okay
fine you're calling this evil i'm
telling you look
i'm telling you look i i have the same
internal experience when i see somebody
murdered i have the same inner feeling
it's wrong
however i don't have the same narrative
as you that that person will never see
justice that death is the ultimate end
that's your own personal outlook in life
don't superimpose it on me don't put
your way of seeing the world on me i
don't put my way of seeing the world on
you let's have a dialogue
an exchange point of views you see it as
the ultimate end i personally don't
think adolf hitler uh
escaped
the evils of what he did by killing
himself
i think adolf hitler right now is being
tormented and he's paying
he's paying for all the evils he did
that's the narrative i live with now if
you think adolf hitler lived a luxurious
life he lived in a lapa luxury for many
years he was europe's most powerful man
he went down
uh you know you know his last
years in life
you know he was pampered he was the king
of europe yeah
for many years you like i mean he lived
in lapa luxury
if you think he killed all those human
beings and got away with it
you're tormenting yourself with that
belief you walk around and you see the
world as nihilistic and evil
that gentleman stephen fry
he's choosing unknowingly unknowingly
he's choosing nihilism
he sees the world when he dies
when he's close to death the life is
going to become more and more unbearable
for him look in philosophy we have
we have this thing we call nihilism
and
atheism only leads to there there are no
other roads there are two possible roads
the natural religion
that we're inborn were born with this
something within us
and there's more to this experience that
we're living right now or nihilism there
are no there are no other options
anybody out there who has a third option
i dare you to bring it to me i dare you
please i'm asking you to bring it
there are only two options that man
stephen fry he is unknowingly picking
nihilism he will
suffer exponentially over the years in
his own mind because every the the
better his life is i know he's maybe a
famous actor he's rich
the more difficult is going to be to
leave this world because in his mind
it's the ultimate end
and his mind the more beautiful his life
is right now the harder it is to be to
part
people who suffer he's gonna envy that
child with cancer one day he's gonna be
like you know what that child never
tasted these luxuries i did and then it
was ripped away from him for eternity
he died at a young age i end
as he gets older he's going to want to
envy that he's going to envision like
you know what i wish i never tasted
these pleasures in life i wish i never
saw the beauty because being having it
ripped out of my hand is so
painful
then i'm paying the debt for all this
enjoyment i had all the beauty i saw
there's a debt at the end when i exit
there's a debt why because this
narrative i live with is that the debt
is it eternal lights out
eternal separation that's what they
believe
so there's gonna be a time where he's
gonna have a mind shift he's gonna have
a paradigm shift where he's gonna be
like hey i see the wisdom now and dying
very young
i know it sounds morbid
i know it sounds weird that's because
you're in a certain stage in your life
right now if you can
try to have
uh
some introspection of how certain other
people's lives may be at a certain time
at a certain time
you can have a paradigm shift
like for instance in the quran it says
when god sends them on the storm he sees
all of a sudden they get on their knees
now now they're now they have they
they're in touch with the fitra why
because they're seeing the ultimate end
and they're like hey there's something
beyond
there's something more this can't be it
i see absurdism early on in this
conversation i talked about absurdism
that we're born with this inner yearning
for something more
and we human beings have a unique
capability
human beings have a unique capability
that we're touched with the idea that
the capability to visualize living
forever yeah human beings live in our
minds we live in the past
we live in the future and we live in the
present we have this ability
to
think of the future remember the past
all while living in the present no
animal can do this
and we have this yearning to live
forever let's put within us
we have this yearning within us
they're saying look i'm in touch with
this yearning now i see it clearly all
my personalities all the experience i've
had in life
in a second because
in a second
you have an eternity of wisdom flash
before your eyes and all of a sudden you
believe in god that yet when god he
hears your prayers and he calms the
winds and he brings you back to the
shore and you think oh we lost our mind
for a second
god is telling you look think about when
you have these paradigm shifts
your fit your fitrah
your
natural religion the natural religion
you are born with
becomes glaringly obvious to you
becomes glaringly
obvious
and
no logical argument can supersede that
no scientific experiment can supersede
that it's so this is what we call an
intuitive fact you know it firsthand
so i'm telling you these gentlemen when
they're saying they're atheist it's
comfortable and popular to say it now
but when they're on their deathbed
their death their time on their deathbed
will seem like an eternity wow wow that
is really that's that's really really
deep for someone who ruminates over that
what you're saying and i started the
show i mean we're going to get into some
really uh powerful stuff in lightning
and what you're saying basically at the
end of the day it's going from
meaningless to meaningful and it doesn't
make sense to just live a meaningless
life going back to uh uh i have just a
few more questions before we conclude i
want to get these uh in and they're
going to be based around some of these
videos i'm going to show you but just to
touch back upon
the um
chat is he still champ the uh
jon jones he's still is he still the
ufc champ
i think they stripped him from you know
they stripped him from his title yeah
yes he hasn't fought in a while i
believe uh i mean uh no no he's not he's
not trapped he's not cool
but he was he
he's not retired but they stripped him
of his title he's been inactive i want
to give just one example how do you
think if he had more of a structure just
like you have in training camp you have
structure imagine you go to training
camp and you don't have some structure
you know no discipline like how to go
ahead and what to do from a to z i mean
it's not going to make for you know a
good routine and at the end of the day
to a good chance to becoming a good
champion but same thing in life how
islam gives you structure so do you
think from one of the things for
instance because a lot of the mishaps
and i really feel sorry and bad for for
uh jon jones want the best for him and
when you see a lot of the mishaps have
been around alcohol
and you talk you talk about how islam is
say just just one example you can give
you know so many but just babies you
know saving islam saving babies from
from being born with alcohol syndrome
which affects 40 40 to 50 000 children
uh born in this country a year but just
if
if john jones was able to have that
structure that islam gives him
right and just one of the prohibitions
is alcohol you know what i mean what do
you think how that would affect his life
and enhance him as a human being
i would say it benefits 99 of the
population to not touch drugs or alcohol
in my personal opinion
uh
i think alcohol is one of the most
unhealthy things both physically and
mentally
uh it's it's a curse on the world in my
opinion if you look at the history of
alcohol
it's been a curse on the world
um i'd rather be
i i i hate i dread to be in a room with
drunk people
um there they become inhibited and
violent
and i think jon jones's life could have
been much better if he uh had that
paradigm if he was completely
disassociated from enjoying alcohol or
drugs in any way
uh he could have a much
more um
a successful personal life let's call it
but again i don't want to judge anybody
i don't want to say that
i don't want to single out john jones i
think i'd rather say it in general let
me let me take it back in general most
people will have a more successful
personal life and in terms of health for
your liver etc
if they never
came across alcohol or drugs because
it's a dependency it's a social
lubricant right people do it because
they feel awkward they feel nobody
tastes alcohol and thinks it's delicious
in my opinion it's the most disgusting
vile at least in my personal opinion
it's the most disgusting and vile uh
substance you can taste you know if
somebody tasted that i don't know how
they can keep drinking it and
it's but people do it because
it
makes them more sociable they have the
courage now they have this liquid
courage to act and
and approach people and that that's what
is it it allows them to connect
they're connecting around alcohol it
makes it's a social uh uh
stimulus
but you can have other you can connect
as human beings in other ways that are
far better
far superior
and uh you know anybody familiar with
the history of alcohol knows what occurs
i i can tell you that i think even
alcohol might be worse than hard drugs
for what it's done to the world you know
it was a curse on humanity
and when you study the history this just
amazed me the story when you look at
when people because obviously the
prohibitions just come in islam and say
do's and don'ts but you know first you
know the beginning was getting to know
your creator and then when you know your
credit you love your creator and then
you trust him that he knows what's best
for you and then you know the companions
disciples of prophet muhammad when the
injunction came down you know to
prohibit alcohol because it came in
stages they had so much of a love and
connection to their creator the one and
only created that heavens the earth
and love for the hereafter for paradise
that at the end of the at the end they
were just you know spitting it out of
their mouth they swallowed it with
throwing it up they say the city the the
cities was was filled with alcohol on
the streets you know
so i just think about that i'm like
amazed you know with someone like him or
others you know there's truly such a
great benefit and one other thing that
you mentioned if you can just clear it
and i'll go to the next point how
because oftentimes when he people hear
islam they think it's a new religion
it's something that just came with
muhammad peace and must be upon him and
all the prophets but you talk about
islam came from the beginning the
conscious concept of submitting your
will to the one and only created the
heavens and the earth and it's not based
around the history just like you had the
jfk assassination people are still
trying to figure it out you know let
alone trying to figure out you know what
happened back two to three thousand
years ago
yeah let's let's talk about the
hierarchy of facts okay the number one
most certain type of fact is we call
philosophy intuitive facts
if i have a headache i know it even
though scientists cannot prove that i
have a headache they can they can put
all sorts of electrodes on me they can
scan my brain they can
i might be having a headache and they
can't detect it
but they believe me i have a headache
because they've had headaches in the
past
you know you have a headache even if
your iq is
you don't have to be a logician to know
you have a headache
you know you have a headache it's
immediate
then we have logical facts such as you
know mathematical facts deductive facts
abductive facts one plus one equals two
that's an analytical fact it's true by
definition
it's certain it's it has a high level of
certainty
then we have inductive facts
something is hot or cold
something is tall or short we can
measure how how long a football field is
okay we're out going out there in the
world and we're using instruments and
we're measuring the world we're using
inductive
um uh
logic to see you know how heavy is a
rock how heavy how dense is this
material these are things we do by
experiment
and then after that even lower is
historical facts historical facts are
the most dubious
because many things happen in history
historians reported they contradict each
other they're completely wrong one of
them has to be wrong one of them could
be they could both be wrong or one of
them is is wrong at least there are many
dubious facts in history such as the
assassination of the jfk we're not we're
still not sure how jfk died
we're still not sure exactly if there
was two shots three shots uh there are
many competing theories we had cameras
we have eyewitnesses we have the top
minds of the world trying to figure out
what happened exactly to
jfk that we still don't we still don't
know
was it the man with the umbrella that
shot him on the grassy no we don't know
we still we still have competing
theories conspiracies was that you know
they found a bullet next to his body
when he was in the hospital it was that
bullet put there afterwards
etc they have so many competing theories
they cannot be certain
and that's with primary source materials
now
a primary source material is for
instance the footage of jfk being shot
a secondary source material is somebody
who heard a story from somebody who was
there that person wasn't there
but he heard a story of somebody who he
claims he talked to was there that's a
secondary source of material so there
are degrees of even house how certain a
historical fact can be
so what does islam base our religion on
it bases our religion on the first
category intuitive facts
the fitra the natural born religion is
within everybody is born on the fitrah
we don't want to confuse islam per se
with the fitter
because you could have never heard of
muhammad ali
and the quran
and be upon the fitra for anybody who
disagrees with that read the quran what
does it say it says it says tell the
christians and the jews
that abraham was on the right path
before the scriptures
abraham was on the right path before the
scriptures why abraham was upon the
fitra he was already upon
the natural religion adam alaihi sallam
was already upon the fitra
meaning we are born with a religion how
do you know this religion i know the
same way i know i have a headache
i know it the same way i know i have a
headache the quran tells you look you
didn't always exist how did you come
into this world
you're going to come into this the next
world exactly like you came into this
world forget all your logicians and
scientists and all that they can never
understand
existence existence is superior
it's greater than any neil degrasse
tyson can wrap his mind around
i used to be
non-existent and i exist now the same
way i came into this world i'll come
into the next and that for me is a very
comforting narrative i don't see a child
when he dies i don't see it as the
ultimate end
i see the same way he came into this
world he'll come into the next one how i
don't know i just trust in god look how
he created the dunya
i always like to tell people imagine
think of this thought experiment imagine
we had all the knowledge we have today
and somehow we were observing existence
we're just purely logical
minds we're outside of existence we're
just observing existence
before the event of life we're just
seeing
the planetary bodies form we're seeing
we're seeing
physics and chemistry in action
we're seeing the big bang we're seeing
the universe develop
and one of us says look one one one day
there will be life
billions of years from now there's going
to be this thing called life
we haven't we couldn't never guess that
by watching the development of the
universe a cold dead universe would be
in a hot state by then but you know what
i mean i mean cold figuratively there's
no life there's no love there's no
warmth there's no compassion it's just
building blocks and chemistry we can
never
imagine this leap from
a cold dead universe figuratively
speaking to a universe where there's
contemplation
friendship
love
uh
the desire to connect with a higher
uh
a being
we could never make that logical leap
there's nothing to bring us to that to
make that leap yet it does it did exist
it did happen
love compassion friendship exists in
this world things that are outside of
chemistry
and physics and we know these things
certainly we know them firsthand
that's why when that gentleman is saying
when that gentleman stephen fry is
saying i see evil in the world he's
admitting he's admitting already to the
fitra
because there is no evil or good in the
world
without first admitting there is a god
because only god can make something good
or evil
you cannot have good or even that's why
hume was telling look we're going to say
we're atheists we can't say ot
we can't say the world ought to be a
certain way we have to say the world is
that way
that kid died he's just chemistry in
physics and leave it at that don't admit
to seeing evil or good in the world
because once you admit to seeing
that things ought to be a certain way
you're saying
that the solemn bonham is true
you're saying that there's there is a
god there is good and evil there's more
to the world
than chemists chemistry and physics
you're admitting it you're taking a
self-defeating position so for me i
don't believe that they're atheistic
when they say nature they don't know
that they're using an expression they
think they're saying they're referring
to something that's literal literally in
out there in the world when i say the
word nature i'm using an expression to
refer to a collective of things
i'm a nominalist i i challenge anybody
out there
i challenge anybody in the world
but i only have three criteria three
and to come here and tell me that
nominalism is incorrect
my number one criteria
is that you understand
the difference between
inductive and deductive logic
number two you understand the problem of
causation and number three
you have a definition of truth
because philosophers don't agree on the
definition of truth
meet these three criteria and let's have
a discussion a civil discussion public
public one you come here and you tell me
that nature is something out there in
the world you come here and you tell me
that randomness is something physic
literally out there in the world it's
incorrect randomness is part of your
imagination
uh nature is part of the imagination
it's a projection of the mind it's a
projection of the mind if anybody
studied immanuel kant he would know this
it's a projection of the mind it's
something you superimpose upon the world
for the world to make sense to you
now i have a thought experiment that
kind of illustrates that but it's pretty
long and it's complicated but in the end
ultimately speaking ultimately speaking
if we're circling back to stephen fry's
point he's admitting the world ought to
be a certain way so he's admitting
there's good and evil in the world and
there cannot be good and evil
without
god
i want to get a couple of just couple
more before we conclude videos and uh
this is this is very nice to see i want
to get your reaction to this from our
from our friend mr joe back in history i
see these sort of cycles of errors of
reason and then faith areas of reason
and faith like the
faith you know dark ages then the
enlightenment then you know it goes dark
again like you know the arab world was
flourishing it created you know algebra
was named after al-jabbar and they kind
of and then you know islam came and kind
of went to an era of faith and it kind
of slowed thing well islam originally
was the they were
scientists man i mean they were they if
you look at this the early islamic world
they were the ones that
were the most advanced at one point in
history they were the ones that were
pushing mathematics and science and and
reason and logic you know it's just it
comes in cycles man it comes in cycles
of suppression and dominance and you
know the the real concern is
unstoppable dictatorships like china and
russia and when when there's no dissent
and no discussion and this is what we
have to realize
it
really is it's uh it's an odd thing
because i think there's there's genuine
beauty
in
most religions like you can you can
learn a lot about
human beings and the sort of uh the way
they
they use ethics and morals in their life
and what they've learned from their
religion yeah you know when you watch
the muslims uh gather around mecca and
go around the circle if you don't think
there's something kind of beautiful
about that
amazing about that they all
peacefully get there they all dress the
same and they all like move around this
thing and show respect obviously it's
doing something for them it has this
profound effect on them yeah
i've got a lot of friends who are arabs
i've spent a lot of time in the middle
east um i love them they're awesome uh
there are some factions that
say we got to go blow ourselves up and
that's obviously some factions of
christianity
too right
100 absolutely in america right and i
guarantee you absolutely we were being
invaded and attacked
by muslims all the time
it'd probably be some radical
fundamentalist christians that would
want to do the same thing
right that some some muslim sex have
done yeah so you know getting into the
there's good and bad that come from
religion when it's used by people to
keep themselves in power and repress
other people that's really bad yeah and
when it's used to do unto others as you
would have them do unto you yeah that's
really good um you know don't lie
cheaters you know don't kill other
people don't steal those are good those
are good ways to run society
uh that was really nice to see i don't
know if you got a chance to see that you
know it's kind of a turn uh for the for
the better what do you think
i love the fact that they're so
open-minded you know they finally
started to differentiate between
different types of muslims you know the
muslims that are creating all the chaos
are such a small fraction they're less
than one percent they get all the
attention
and a lot of
personalities out there like to exploit
that to try to create fear and
pump their books and make millions of it
recently muhammad hijab had a dialogue
with jordan peterson which i loved
i find that those two individuals did
something so great in one podcast
they said look let's not let's be honest
here there were two individuals trying
to be honest and have a civil discussion
they didn't seem to be trying to push a
book or an agenda or ideology they were
look let's have a civil discussion and i
found it so amazing
and so
honestly precious
that jordan peterson walked back his
comments about muhammad ali salaam being
a warlord
and that they had such a great and it's
it's an absurdity to say muhammad ali
is a warlord it's an absurdity to say
the conquest of mecca
the conquest of mecca
is pure
100 percent
proof
that islam is a peaceful religion who
knows the quran better than muhammad ali
salam ask you eddie who knows it better
than him
who could interpret it better than him
is there a single human being in history
is there
no he had the quran at that time he
conquered his enemies his enemies were
his footstool
and he let them all not only live but
thrive
and he let them all be in peace he said
today is a day of mercy he conquered
them without the sword without the sword
you name me one other human being don't
you dare interpret the quran don't you
dare interpret the quran any other way
than the way muhammad ali salaam did he
conquered mecca
after a broken treaty people have to
know that
the prophet ali salam was living in
peace with the pagans
they were sharing they were doing a time
share of mecca at that time till the
pagans broke the contract and this is
bedrock history it's embedded in the
quran the quran is telling you look they
broke the treaty this is why i'm giving
you this special permission it can't be
a lie because the muslims would have
been like how could the quran say they
broke the shooting when they didn't
the muslims were living the quran alive
at that time
they witnessed the broken treaty the
koran came down and said look the treaty
has been broken this cannot be a lie
because the muslims would have been
shocked
there was an event that broke i don't
want to go too much detail but they
broke the covenant that they had
together
and muhammad using the correct
interpretation of the quran the correct
interpretation the only interpretation
we have
there is no interpretation outside no
interpretation could supersede the
interpretation of muhammad alaihissalam
would you take interpretation of any
other scholar other than muhammad
would you take any other interpretation
no how did he interpret all the verses
of the quran together
the accumulation of the quran
99 of it was already revealed at this
point
what did he how did he practice the
quran the quran he conquered his enemies
without a weapon being drawn
he conquered them peacefully he let them
keep their
go he let them keep their riches their
property
he allowed them to leave or stay he
allowed them to leave or stay
no other human being in history did this
except for umar bin khattab a follower
of muhammad and
when they conquered jerusalem they did
the same thing why it's the sunnah
it's how they interpret the quran they
even made a hollywood movie what was it
the uh
the kingdom of heaven yes yes
don't you dare interpret the quran for
us you know so many personalities i
don't even say the name they say look
this is how the quran this is what the
quran says look what the scholar said
don't you dare interpret the quran
higher
outside of what muhammad did don't you
dare don't you dare muhammad's only
expansive war in his he ever had was the
conquest of mecca he went from medina to
mecca he expanded from medina to mecca
only because a treaty was broken if they
never broke that treaty the pagans would
be there till today
so today they would be there
nobody should ever interpret the quran
outside of prophet muhammad's actions he
had the entirety of the quran at that
time or let's say 99 of it
let's call it 98
and he practiced the quran nobody should
ever dare to reinterpret it differently
than what he did now
with what joe rogan said he's correct
it is beautiful to see all the muslims
praying together there's a harmony
instead of gathering around alcohol
we are gathering our own god
yes that is our social lubricant that is
what brings us together we have a system
now look if you want to be
if you want to be in the west and you
want to socialize well you got to go to
a club well guess what the number one
thing that keeps the club funded is
alcohol you have to drink if you don't
drink you're not part of the party you
don't want to hang out with us you want
to socialize with us
we have a different
focal point
and when muslims when muslims make sujud
when they put their forehead on the
floor they're saying the the
significance of that
is that look i know god is true i submit
my will to god i submitting my intellect
that's when the the brain the intellect
is lower than the heart
gazelli says to us
the heart not that lump of flesh in your
chest
but that inner experience you have that
inner
point point of awareness you have
when you lower your head and you put
your head on the floor you're putting
your in like lower than that than the
heart the heart you know allah directly
you know god by the fitra
you were touched
by the sign of god when you were born
and i always tell people think about
before you were
you were released into this world you
know when you were in your mother's womb
you didn't know your name
you didn't know the dunya you didn't
know about the world around you you
didn't know about uh
eating drinking sleeping you didn't know
about the cycles of you didn't know
anything all you had was perfect unity
in existence all you had was this fitta
that you lived that you dwelled within
you were aware of this fitra you are
incubated in the fitrah then you were
released in this world and now there's a
million thousand there's a trillion
competing theories such as nature
randomness etc these things i didn't
know them i knew something way before
them
all these things are encompassed within
my uh
experience of awareness
i had awareness first and then these
things are embedded in awareness they
cannot be greater than my awareness
and what was i aware of this one unity
this unbroken unity we all know god
before we enter this world we all
experience god before we enter this
world this is in the quran the quran
asks you
the quran tells you before you enter
this world you all gave me the shahada
you all said god you are a one you are
one god
now you can take this literally or
figuratively nonetheless in the quran is
telling you you know about god before
you enter this world so when you go to
mecca and you do sujud you're returning
back to this oneness you know in the
bible in the bible the gospel it says
they say that jesus is claiming they
claim that jesus said
you won't enter the kingdom of heaven
till you're be born again
now christians have many beliefs on what
this means i think it's telling you go
back to the fitrah when you were born
you had a religion already before
anybody told you about it abraham was
upon the truth before he the scriptures
we have this inner
religion that we're born with that's why
when you're born in this world you're
looking to connect that's where
absurdism remember we talked about
absurdism early on before
it would be absurd for us to be born
with a religion
and there not be a god
it's absurd to think about it i'm using
the term religion
loosely the more accurate term will be
the fitra it would be absurd to be born
with this idea that you want to connect
back to this oneness that you first came
from this eternal oneness
and there's a lot to be said about what
it means what does oneness mean we can
talk about this as well if you have the
time ready
because oneness
the quran is secretly telling you
something that you already know over and
over again
over and over again that's why people
look you can give them all the logical
arguments you want in the world they
always end up saying look you know what
makes sense to me god is one that's it
the quran is telling you look the
message is
the message is going to be protected
you know what the the quran's message is
very simple
oneness
is so glaringly obvious
you can never pervert it it's impossible
and i i'll try to i'll try to make it
more clear why because i think we all
know it secretly it's just hard to
verbalize it's very difficult eddie to
verbalize but it's known
it's not believed it's known
you know if you ask if you ask a hundred
christian experts
who is god
it's a very complicated answer
it's a very complicated answer even
those who believe in the trinity have a
different variation of trinity even it's
a very complex answer
you try to hand down a complex answer
over years
the first 300 years they don't none of
the following fathers would agree with
what we have today none of them uttered
these kind of uh uh ideas they matured
over time
it's a very complex answer if you ask
the jews or the muslims
what is god they're gonna tell you god
is one that's it it's simple
it's simple man we didn't we don't have
we don't have
a variety of answers
and we don't need a variety of answers
just one
just one and and this is very very
powerful
i'm going to try to explain why but i'm
trying to explain a very advanced and
difficult idea
um
you know aristotle told us look all
knives
have something in common okay it's a
classic example we've talked about in
the past
all knives have something in common
if i show you a plastic knife eddie
you're going to say look that plastic
knife has something in common with a
metal knife yes or no
if you're referring to it as a knife
then it has the essence of knife
if i change the essence i changed the
thing
if i change its essence
i've changed this thing if i take that
plastic knife eddie and i melt it down
and i transition i reform it into a fork
you're going to say look that's no
longer a knife it no longer shares that
one thing with that metal knife over
there it doesn't have that thing in
common with it anymore therefore it is
no longer a knife
if i change the essence of something
eddie i've changed that thing it's no
longer that thing
now when we when philosophers ask what's
the essence of human beings it's a very
complex answer
human beings are part physicality and
we're part concept part part of us is a
concept so for instance a knife
i look at this
i look at this
pen here
it's part material substance
okay it's part material
but it's also part concept because a
pencil
it's a tool to write part of the essence
of a pencil and the essence of a knife
is that it cuts
part of the essence
and a peso has to write if this thing
doesn't write anymore i would say it's a
broken pencil if i melt it down and turn
it into a i don't know
a paper weight you can see look it's no
longer a pencil it doesn't write its
function is not to write no more it
doesn't do that it's changed it has
changed
it is no longer a pencil you've changed
its essence
a pencil
aristotle told us look it's concrete
it's material but also you have to put a
concept on it it has to give a thing
that's intended to write
and that's a concept cutting is a
concept you can't put cutting in a test
tube cutting is something that's held in
a mind it's a concept
nature like we talked earlier is a
concept you have to
you have to say look flowers grass rain
cycle wind cycle
uh
airflow uh
monetary uh planetary bodies these are
particular things add this concept to it
there you have nature nature is part
material
and part concept it's it's this
compounded idea
it's two pieces you put together
human beings
are part physicality part concept i'll
give you a a a very classic example and
then we'll move on okay i'll give you a
classic example there's something called
the ship of thesis very important for
anybody out there hoping to study
philosophy you have to know the ship of
thesis thesis has a ship
it has 99 parts every day one part is
worn out and he has to change that part
after 30 days he's changed 30 parts
every day he's going out sailing on that
ship every day he comes back he has to
change a new part
after 99 days eddie that ship has been
completely changed the original parts
are completely gone it's all new parts
and that ship is still sailing back and
forth and everybody's referring to it as
the ship of thesis
and then all those old 99 parts i put
them in a warehouse somewhere and one
day i put them back together and now i
have two ships of thesis
and i ask you which one is the original
ship you'll be like well the new one is
the one we've been sailing on it has the
history of the ship of thesis but the
old one the the the one you just made
put together has the original parts
and you're like well it could be either
way they kind of they're kind of both
the ship of theseus and you would be
correct in a way because the ship of
theseus is a concept
it's a material substance out there in
the world sailing on the water but it's
also a concept there's a dualism here
there's material and there's
concept
now what if i told you eddie
if i told you look there's only one pen
there's only one
because when i tell you pen remember
you're trying to connect this concept to
them because there's so many pens in the
world you have to say look they all have
one thing in common they're all right
that becomes the essence of pen
but when i what if i told you eddie no
no no no
there's only one pen in the entire
universe and there's never gonna be
another pen and there's always been this
one pen and this pen is unchanging
now if a pen
there's many if there's many
and it's it's a changing thing a pen
could be sharpened that a pen can get
old a pen can break it changes it goes
through cycles
now i'm attaching a concept to it it's
no longer just a thing literally out
there if i told you eddie how much does
a pen wait we're gonna be like look pens
vary in weight
if i told you
eddie what uh
what color is a pen well pens come in
different colors you would have to say
look you have to tell me if look there's
pens out there in the world but you have
to be flexible there's concepts
that super that come along with pens
okay
it's not objective anymore a pen is a
subjective thing this is a very key
point a pen is now a subjective element
in the world
a pen could be black white green heavy
short tall sharpened not sharpened it
comes in a variety of ways however if
there was only one pen one
this is the key point now
and this pen doesn't change
it never changes
and i'm telling you it will never change
it has never changed it has always
existed this is a divine pen it's a
divine pen you understand what i mean
when i say divine it will never change
it will never erode it will never need
sharpening
then when i ask you about this pen now
your answers can finally become
objective
they can finally become true
because anything i say of pens as a
collective is subjective however if a
pen is singular and divine then it is
objectively true the quran is telling
you that god is one
unchanging never will change
eternal this is the correct definition
of god god could be no other way that is
the definition of a literal god it is
telling you that god the quran is
telling you
that god is literal it is not a concept
in your mind like nature nature is a
concept in your mind because when i ask
you about nature to teach me about
nature you have to point if i was
teaching a child about nature i would
have to point to the
the the flowers in the grass i would
have to point to the clouds in the sky i
would have to point to particulars
that's why in islam we're not saying god
is a particular you're going to point to
a
old man above the sky
the cons our our belief in god is not
conceptual it is literal
your belief in nature and randomness etc
you always have to point to particulars
god doesn't god's existence does not
depend on particulars god is literally
true
god is literally out there that's why
when you say
nature you're appealing to a force that
depends on particulars and your paradigm
and your imagination we're saying god
doesn't depend on our imagination when
all minds are dead when all human beings
die god will still exist this is what
the quran says when all have perish
there will remain the face of god god is
telling you
he is literally true and that is the
correct definition of god
that is the only that is the that is the
self-evident
definition of god the quran gets it
perfectly correct
much respect for what you were saying
earlier just a couple more questions and
um
i just want to get in much respect for
like you said earlier jordan peterson i
think this can be a great catalyst for
others to open up their platforms and
instead of talking about muslims talk
with muslims
really nice to see uh joe rogan also uh
you know watching the kaaba and the
muslims going around you know practicing
that pure monotheism so
inshallah this can be a turn for the
better now just in concluding because
consciousness and then you have the soul
and then how would you answer this
question for somebody who has been
you have one individual who's kind of
just went viral and and we can avoid
this but a lot of times our youth you
know they end up gravitating sometimes
towards these things they inquisitive
they're looking you know but then you
see the whole world opens up to
individuals like this but then you see
the anxiety is through the roof like for
instance in this case so so
about a week not today but about a week
ago
i sold my soul
yeah i'm saying
and uh ever since i sold my soul i
haven't been happy ever since
you know what i'm saying
um
hey yo
man you ain't gotta believe me it ain't
what it is i i s like i'm not even
capping
it's because listen i had to do it you
know i'm saying because like
i had to do it because i was trying to
make it like you feel me
like
and as of when i was like setting my
soul
um
like there was things that i could
sacrifice about and stuff like that and
i sacrificed myself
i couldn't sacrifice anybody but like
but when you saw your soul you got to
sacrifice someone that you would love
and i sacrificed myself and stuff like
that someone who feels they've gotten
that far they've sold their soul
and obviously if your soul is sold you
probably you'll be dead because you
can't sell your soul it's it's not yours
to begin with you don't have a title for
it like so what what do you when you
hear something like that someone who's
sold themselves pretty much for fame
for fortune but at the end of the day it
equals misery what would you tell
someone like this
you know and others who uh have you
heard of this island boy
no i've never heard of that i've never
seen that in my life
i wish i
could no i honestly i i've never i don't
know is that a famous individual
yeah these are the young island boys who
just uh hit viral they're pretty famous
now yeah
are there rappers singers or
entertainers or whatever they're there
um
you know like i mean i don't want to
psychoanalyze the guy but but then if
you ask the youth the youth who you want
to stay away from this even muslim youth
you said you know the island boys is
like yeah we know the island boys
you know later today but i have to
google the island boys just so i'm not
out of touch yeah and i'm gonna have to
listen to their music and i'm gonna have
to kind of like you know try to
understand like who are these people not
because i generally i'm gonna be
entertained by it but just because i'm
curious to know how did they get here
like look i i look at him and to me he
looks tormented
uh you know you look at his
you know what he's done to his body you
can look at his
his
ability to communicate now i'm sure he's
a very talented rapper
but he's trying to express himself and
he's trying to say look i sold my soul
now
if he's
if he's if somebody sells his soul that
means they have nothing left i'm
assuming that's what he means yeah he's
got nothing left because
our the essence of a pen is that it
writes the essence of a human being is
their soul
outside of our soul what are we we're
just rotting flesh yes so i think he's
saying look uh
because you know what eddie you know you
know what's the greatest hell
in this world the greatest hell in this
world
is to be a slave to your desires
there is no pleasure
anymore when your desires have overrun
your world now imagine eddie we
we talked about this in the past but
let's reiterate to make it more clear if
i give you a chocolate cake you might
enjoy chocolate cake you might enjoy and
then i make you eat a second one you're
gonna enjoy a little bit less and i
force you to eat a third and i put a gun
to your head and make you eat a fourth
and a fifth now you're eating chocolate
cake and you're in torture and i make
you i bring you a seventh and an eighth
and now you're throwing up and i make
you eat a ninth and now just seeing
chocolate cake you're you're shaking you
don't
the same thing that once gave you
pleasure is not
burdening you
why
because in this life
first you have to suffer
you have to have a desire
that desire is a discomfort when you
relieve that discomfort
then you have this experience we call
pleasure this is in the quran
for every hardship there is a relief
for every hardship there's a relief the
quran repeats it twice because in this
life we're stuck in the cycle
of hardship and relief you're hungry
it's discomfort
it's a hardship then you eat you're
relieved but guess what there's hunger
again
hunger comes again it's cyclical and
then you have to relieve it again
and this world we're stuck in this cycle
of hunger and relief hunger and relief
however
however
the one who
is a slave to that desire he can't
control that desire he doesn't struggle
with it he doesn't fight back
he doesn't limit how much he eats he
doesn't limit how much he consumes
he thinks that more consumption is
better he becomes desensitized to that
relief
so if you're gluttonous if you overeat
you never allow your body to be hungry
you never have a ramadan you never
recharge your batter you know the
ramadan is a great
antidote for depression
because in the west we have a lot of
depression why do we have a lot of
depression we have too much food and
drink we have too much free time we have
too much
pleasure not enough hardship
you know during the pandemic they shut
my gym down the police was at my door
all the time
let me tell you something i realized how
much i love
my gym like when i go in the gym i'm so
re-energized i love it man i love my why
because the doors are reopened they re
i'm not trying to put my gym here at all
please please forgive me it's just an
example a recent a recent recharge i've
had the fact that it was taken away from
me for over a year the police were
literally at my door banging on my door
forcing me to leave the like
i really it got it got that it was that
bad not that bad it kind of got really
bad and that was the i was the focal
point of all the gyms in montreal like
it's a long story but they were really
after me particularly
and
literally they came to my gym 16 times
in the year and three times in one day
at one point yeah i had a huge issue
with the police like they really didn't
want me in there they really like
adamantly they didn't want me in there
and
it was such a difficult time but now i
really appreciate my gym every time i go
in the gym man i'm like i i remember how
much i love to be here
and i think the west needs some of that
they need a ramadan
the west needs a rum a yearly ramadan a
year you know and they try to do it
eddie they try to do a
sober november or something like that i
don't know i forget is it october sober
october
where they say okay we're not going to
drink i don't know if it's october or
november forgive me i'm not sure which
one but they say look we're not going to
drink all month we're not going to smoke
weed all month we're not going to do
this all month even they see even they
see they understand the prescription
islam gives you
but islam what the beauty of it is we do
it as a community look we're all not
going to eat
we're all not going to drink we're all
going to do it together it's such a
beautiful
experience
because when you're doing it alone it's
tough
but when you do it as a community you re
you recharge your batteries you have a
vigor for life
chocolate cake chocolate cake tastes
sweet again coffee in the morning at the
end of ramadan the one thing i look
forward to is my morning coffee
i remember how precious my morning
coffee is you reinvigorate yourself you
know uh you know even just stopping your
sexual desires for a month will
reinvigorate you will
remind you you know how precious you
know that experience is you know between
a man and a woman you and your wife
you know you reinvigorate yourself the
west is too
hedonistic like that young man he's
fully tattooed he's got a mouth full of
gold the worst thing that might have
happened to him in his life is that he's
been successful in the rich
because he didn't have the wisdom to
control his desires
he seems like a young man who's already
lived too much of life and he's
desensitized because when you have too
many women eddie when you have too much
pleasure when you have too much
abundance what happens women is no
longer pleasurable to you like chocolate
cake it's no longer pleasurable to you
now you need something more you need
something more edgy
you know the most extreme
sexual type of behaviors are in the
cultures with the most extreme amount of
free sex
because now a woman is not enough
anymore you need something so bizarre so
perverted so uh uh extreme that you're
like hey that's what it takes now for me
to remember to feel what i used to feel
when a woman covers herself up she's
more desirable women have it backwards
they think they're more desirable the
more they show no actually no the man
now sees you as cheaper
actually after he has his way with you
your his his appreciation for you or
your value in his eyes drops
exponentially this is what women don't
don't know men secretly desire you less
after they've had you
the girl who makes a man wait shows him
less
she has more power over his mind there's
nothing that drives a man more crazy
than unattainable women the women in the
west have it backwards it's unfortunate
and they have it to their destiny
they're valued less in my opinion
because they
they appreciate it less why because
they're had more easily
they've cheapened themselves in a
certain way women as a woman is an
extremely precious thing
a human being is an extremely precious
thing
uh food and drink friendship
everything's every resources are an
extremely precious thing however
when they're had an abundance
when their supply is too high
um their value goes down this just you
know that's the fundament you know you
know the basics of the fundamental
principle of economics and i don't want
to like human beings to economics but
there is a such thing as sexual market
value
supply and demand too much supply
you know too much supply demand goes
down
and it's a shame that people don't
understand this
if you go back uh more in time you can
see that you know the institution of
marriage was something that was held
high and valuable but it seems just
deteriorating you know as we're getting
more advanced but just more morally
corrupt but you hit a
good point look at look at this function
in the way like like relationship excuse
me relationships in i would say in the
western world have never been so
unsuccessful people are getting married
less than ever and they're getting
divorced more than ever
your likelihood of having successful
marriage a nuclear family in the west is
super low like if you want to have a
husband a wife and three kids a nuclear
family
which is the bedrock of civilization
you could tell how healthy a
civilization is by how healthy the
nuclear family is
the more abundant the nuclear families
are the more healthy the civilization
you can't build a civilization outside
of a nuclear family
for instance imagine
imagine you have 50 couples you have a
civilization of 100 people and each you
have 50 cups so you have 100 people you
couple them that's 50 people they each
only have one child that means the next
generation only have 25 people
and you can only have 12.5 couples
and then that generation only has one
one child each
now you're down to
12 children
12 and five children and so on now you
can only have six couples you need
to a couple a male and a female
and three children for a civilization to
grow and thrive
that has been severely hampered in the
west why
the kids today are two
um
they're too bombarded
and has a lot to do with social media
because now today
they don't have relationships anymore
like like we had in our generations
where you get to know each other you get
married and you have child that doesn't
happen anymore now it's a hookup culture
yeah why should i marry this girl when i
got five other girls messaging me for
the same weekend so girls what happens
is it's called a race to the bottom
eddie
a woman today who saves herself
she's competing with women who go out on
the first date and have sexual
intercourse with it with a man
so what they have to do now it's called
a race to the bottom women in the past
women in the 1920s
if you wanted to marry her if you wanted
to marry her you had to buy her a house
first you had to ask her father for
permission you had to go through all
these hurdles
and all the women held their own like
this all the woman said no we're not
giving any sexual relation to any man
till he marries us buys us a house has a
good job et cetera asks my family for a
vision my father has to like it my
mother has to like et cetera
men had to jump through so many hurdles
that they were on their best behavior
they reached for the skies and when they
got the woman they appreciated her
because the guy broke his bank he broke
his bankroll to have her
he
it was a it was a very difficult thing
to get her
now that he has her he appreciates her
he's literally you know done everything
he can and now women it's a race to the
bottom why because women
in in the 1920s if a girl would sleep
with a man before marriage they would
shame her she was ostracized you broke
this agreement we have with one another
we're not going to give men
a woman for for cheap women's value the
demand was so high because the supply
the the amount you had to do
the amount you had to do to get a woman
was so difficult now what happens is
it's a race to the bottom the women
instead of waiting three dates now they
wait two dates and then instead of
waiting two dates they wait one date and
now they don't you don't even have to
take me on a date they call it netflix
and chill just call me up or watch
netflix and have relations it's become a
race to the bottom the women have to
give up so easily why because that guy
has four other girls five other girls
texting him it's a it's it's a moral
race to the bottom
and what happens is now they've become
used once a destroy almost
use her once and find the next girl
there's been an abundance
now i don't want to single out women but
you know there's a lot to what i'm
saying but biologically speaking
biologically speaking men are more
hardwired to behave this way
but yet women now are behaving this way
why because they're trying to keep up
with the demand if you want to meet a
man
you're competing with a bunch of women
who are ready right now to send them
nude photos of yourself like it's it's
just
social media it has like super
uh it's been a catalyst for the race to
the bottom
so
try now getting married in this
environment is very difficult thing you
know so that's why you know
a lot of
people right now they almost want to
leave the west to go get married they
want to go into a another country where
it's it you know there's very few places
in the world this is not happening but
there are places in the world because
marrying a woman now today is so
complicated it's so difficult
yeah i don't know what this i can't
remember this but like 80 of divorces
have some social media reference in them
meaning that uh it has to do with uh
infidelity and it arises from social
media i can't remember this it's like 70
or something like that it's a very high
level of like social media has affected
relationships in the west no doubt
yeah that's a whole different topic i
mean the 20 million stds you know
not not to talk about the illegitimate
children the children's lives who are
brought into this world you know by
accident because of these illicit
relationships and the list goes on of
all the detrimental effects it has on
society i was just thinking real quick
before we could it just had me thinking
like you know it's all about you know
this well uh as a
someone who's coached some of the great
champions like george saint pierre and
others at the end of the day like it's
all about the after party it's a you
know it's all about right and the
fighter but if you think about it for
people that say oh this is too hard
islam you know all these do's and don'ts
and whatnot and whatever but the fighter
just this example with the fighter you
know the fighter won't party before his
fight if he's disciplined right he won't
go and party before his fight because he
knows what kind of effects he's going to
have
on him he'll wake up for fajr no i mean
he'll wake up for training right he'll
fast no i don't mean fast he'll actually
uh you know want to make weight so he'll
be starving himself right right and
he'll he'll exclude certain things
include certain things he'll avoid
certain foods i mean he'll pretty much
like suffer tremendously for reaping
certain gains who put himself
in uncomfortable situations almost like
torturing himself now i just was
thinking about that look at like for us
now like when people tease muslims oh
you why you guys not drinking why don't
you go to the party oh why are you
fasting and all that but you have the
model right who's working for vogue
she's throwing up she's got to be
fasting she's like killing herself so
but the after party for us is something
that's everlasting you know to see the
face of your lord to be in jenna the
most pure place you can be and god
almighty allah is saying the one who's
successful who purifies it the soul so
we're trying to purify ourselves our
souls so we can have the everlasting not
just the after party in this life that's
over at a blink of an eye but to get to
jannah you know
now
imagine imagine
look islam is functional what you're
saying is look imagine all the ghettos
in all the world
imagine every ghetto around the world
saying look we're no longer going to pay
interest
how do bankers stay rich eddie how do
they stay richer than the rest of us
interest interest yeah 90 over 95 of the
world's income is made via interest
it's a massive amount we will never if
you took all the money in the world and
gave it back to the banks you would
still owe the money
when they when they print a dollar and
they give it to us they give it to us
with interest on it
you could if you took everybody in the
world if you took all our money eddie
and you compiled it in a huge pile all
our assets the gold the bitcoin the cr
and we gave it back to them we still owe
the money
you can never repay them back until you
say we're not paying interest anymore
you will never you will never pay them
back now imagine the ghettos of the
world said look
we're not going to pay interest no more
all of us collectively imagine you said
all the ghettos of the world said look
we're not going to drink alcohol anymore
we're not going to smoke drugs anymore
we're not gonna fight each other anymore
imagine they said look we're not gonna
have illegitimate children anymore we're
not gonna we're not gonna allow
extramarital sex like we're gonna
imagine what a world it would be
all the ills of our world come from all
the things that are haram think of it
imagine you go in the ghettos in america
and you tell them look don't shoot each
other anymore don't sell drugs anymore
to one another don't pay interest
anymore to these banks don't buy your
homes anymore via interest if we all
collectively say no to the bankers they
have nobody to collect interest from
they have nobody to sell houses to their
market will crash
the house the housing market will be for
free for us we will live we will build
our own houses if they had this
collective type of thinking
if we can unite them if we can get them
together
there there would be many ills of the
world fall by the wayside
like for instance the reason why look if
you have to ask yourself if you if
you know what i think is the greatest
thing you can do in this world is have a
successful marriage with three children
or more
that for me is the most important thing
for me when i die i want to make sure i
did that successfully i had a wife and
three children or more and i taught them
to be good human beings
imagine everybody did that eddie imagine
the whole world did that there would be
no wars because your children wouldn't
go to war because they don't want to go
into that other guy's country to break
to kill him to take his resources they
don't love the dunya they don't love the
riches of this world they're not so imp
they're not so impressed by your fifth
avenue apartment they don't desire it
you know you know plato said something
amazing said look you can't be rich and
be an honest human being also at the
same time why because to get those
riches to have that fifth avenue
apartment i don't totally agree with him
okay i believe you can be rich and be an
honest person okay but he's saying look
so many of
of wealth is gained by
stiffing somebody else
by injuring somebody else
but if people didn't love wealth
so much if they were happy with just the
basics
if they made their needs few eddie
and i'm i'm for pro i'm pro technology
okay i i think you should invent the
computer because it's great and it it's
i love the printing press i love
technology i'm always for technology why
because knowledge and speed of
advancements is great however
i don't i wouldn't invent the computer
if i had the capability just because i
want to live in a luxurious house i
wouldn't you have to invent the computer
and technology because you want to make
the world a better place because you
think you love knowledge we look at this
eddie me and you are sharing ideas
not because necessarily we want to make
money
of course we all want to earn a living
but we love
learning
don't we
we love learning
we love knowledge we're lovers of wisdom
and knowledge
so if the whole world adopted this
mentality
look let's do what's best for building
nuclear families
okay everything else takes a back seat
then you'd have to take it back alcohol
would have to take a back seat
extra marital sex would have to take a
back seat if it's truly what's most
important if it's truly what you desire
uh you know
selling drugs to my neighbor would take
a back seat why because i don't want to
poison my neighbor's ability to raise
children also i don't want to i don't
want money that badly
that i'm willing to poison
my neighbor
so i can have a fancier house you know
because a drug dealer that's what he's
doing
he's poisoning his neighbor
because he wants to have luxuries
i don't care how much you offer me
i will never sell or promote drugs and
alcohol never
i don't care how you know what you know
eddie uh i get offers all the time from
gambling sites they want to promote on
my social media
i would make more money than all my
sponsors collected these guys make so
much money gambling sites will make
they make so much money
and i've been approached by huge
companies over the years
i never even remotely attempted to say
yes
never
because
what's what's gambling i'm taking money
from you
for me to be rich i have to [ __ ] your
account it's such a it's such um
people call it fun if you do it
responsibly no people get addicted to it
and they ruin their lives
i find that imagine the whole world said
look we're not gambling anymore we're
not drinking alcohol anymore we're not
selling drugs no more we're not paying
interest no more
we're gonna raise our children to be
good don't lie don't cheat don't steal
there's no amount of money to turn you
into a liar imagine all human beings
tomorrow
there's no amount of money that will
turn them into a ladder there's no
amount of temptation that will make them
a thief
what kind of world do you think we'd be
living in we'd be living in a beautiful
utopia
all the world needs to make all all the
evils that that gentleman in the
beginning stephen fry
was complaining about all the world
needs
is for us
to raise a generation
of compassionate just human beings and
that's the mission of islam
islam is telling you look raise children
they don't lie cheat steal
and they're not greedy for the dunya
they're not they're not dying
to have that porsche when they see a guy
driving by with a lambo and this and
that you know eddie i've made a lot of
money in my life you'll never see me buy
a lamborghini and show it online and
tell people look at these 500
shirt i have i will never do this i will
never ever in my entire life
indulge in luxuries
why because that makes the youngster
behind me he wants to get luxuries and
you know what he's going to do what it
takes to get luxurious why because he
also wants his his media followers too
he wants to be big on internet he wants
his his piece of the pie
what if you raise an
islam
is is also has a mission yes islam is
divine revelation but islam also has a
divine mission
to turn the world
to turn the world
into
a generation to grow
that's why i always tell people if
you're muslim that means you have an
oath to be the most just and fair human
being
don't forget
you have a oath you took an oath to be
the just and most fair human being
possible
now i know we all have our shortcomings
i'm not perfect i'm far from perfect but
i try every day to be the most just and
fair human being i can and this is the
mission of islam islam is telling you
don't pay interest don't drink alcohol
make have it breed a success raise a
successful family teach them not to be
greedy teach them not to be violent
teach them to be good human beings teach
them to worry about the next life not
this life they don't have a lambo in
this life you don't want a lambo in this
life
you don't need it
you don't need that that youngster i saw
saying he sold the soul he got the lambo
he got the riches but he ain't happy yet
he still doesn't have what he wants
there's no
he still hasn't reached the what we
talked about earlier the kant's son and
bona the greatest good he hasn't found
it yet there's no amount of lambos eddie
there's no amount of of women eddie
it doesn't take that desire
for that
that that greatest good
human beings don't forget
human beings
we have the ability
to picture life as lasting forever
why is that why is that ability there
you know we you know uh thomas sneagle
asked that question
he said look and he's an atheist by the
way
that's why i like to use him he's a he's
a philosophy professor he says look
how come i'm thinking at this level if
i'm just a byproduct of darwinian
mechanisms
why do i think why am i able to think
about meta truth metaphorical truths why
am i thinking at this level what does
that have to do with survival and
reproduction
there seems to be and by the way he's
he's declared himself an atheist forever
like he said i'll never go back on
atheism
no matter how much it seems absurd he
has like this emotional connection with
atheism
that
even if god came down and talked to him
he still has to be atheist basically
what he's trying to tell us
he has a blind
connection he has a blind faith in
atheism but he says look it doesn't make
sense that we able to think
metaphorically it doesn't have nothing
to do
with survival and reproduction
we have this calling we all have this
natural religion that we can't verbalize
we can't point to it we can't use uh we
can't come up with a mathematical
formula to encapsulate it yet we all
know it
but islam also has this mission eddie
and it's very important that we're aware
of it islam
is telling you to breed a generation
of
people human beings that are just and
they cannot be tempted
they cannot be tempted by lamborghini
social media they they they avoid all
this
and that's that's the beauty in islam
we're we're we put humanity first
not the individual we put the group
first what's best for the group it's not
healthy for me to pay interest it's not
healthy for me to buy and sell alcohol
for it's not healthy for the community
so i'm going to put the community ahead
i'm going to put my family you know what
eddie you tell me how many drug dealers
have successful families
the kids grow up saying hey you bought
you you bought me these luxuries in life
by shooting and killing and poisoning
people
he resents his father as he grows up he
thinks my father's a bad guy actually if
you think about it i actually don't want
these these luxurious things or my
father was shot and killed or murdered
or went to jail for 10 years now you
tell me how's his relationship with his
children if he's in jail for 20 years
they all end up jail or dead or hated by
their own family
why because they end up saying look my
wife she's with me because i'm a
gangster and i poison people and she
wants that luxury bag so badly she's
willing to go out let me risk my neck of
getting shot killed or put in jail so
she can have that gucci bag
you know one time i had a student of
mine come in a really rich guy and he
came in with like a forty thousand
dollar gym gucci bag
and i just took it i chucked it across
the uh the generals i took this thing
out of my gym i was so gross like you
know he's a friend of mine he he knows
like we know each other like he's he
came in once upon a time that was the
gucci that was the gucci bag i took it i
threw it across the room
like he's so rich you can put his dirty
filthy equipment sticky that's how rich
he is
and i just couldn't look at it anyway i
just took it i chucked it that's how
meaningless is to me i didn't ask him
for one you know he's so rich he could
buy me one he could snap his fingers and
buy i don't want it
i don't because they put their name
gucci on it now you want me to pay the
prices basically telling the world look
how much excessive money i have
look how rich i am i can spend my
resources on this meaningless
meaningless object
instead of helping the world look let me
just tell you guys how important of a
human being how much resources i've
collected i just took that i just chuck
it across the the cage of the
the gym i i think to me it's garbage
now look i have nothing against people
want to wear gucci you want to wear
gucci that's your business but he was a
friend of mine i was trying to teach him
a little life lesson and uh you know i
think i think me and him
we're good friends okay so like even
though we have very vastly different
perspectives we're still good friends
yeah
well i i promised you guys it'd be
enlightening it'd be really deep we went
really deep you get uh
a great bang for your buck here meaning
that if you guys are truth seekers if
you want to go from meaningless to
meaningful there's a lot to uncover here
you know this is a lot of uh gems here
thank you so much for spending the time
with us and sharing uh reacting some of
these videos and um sharing much of your
thoughts and inshallah this could be a
great great benefit for many to come
inshallah god
it was fun thank you so much thank you
thank you my brother
thank you